si vous prenez les missions en cours de
groupe bienvenue à moustache moustache
et spiritualité
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c
tous ne peut pas faire l'émission
bonsoir
quand il regarde les faits une fois ça
dans ma vie une fois j'ai pris sa place
et j'ai vu que c'était vraiment vraiment
très très difficile
je vous demande d'accueillir celui qui a
relevé le défi que je veux lancer il ya
quelques jours non seulement en se
teignant en blond mais en endossant le
personnage du blond tel qu'il est
profondément à sa manière de manière
entière velléitaire hamas mais je vous
demande d'accueillir série le mac do ba
et là les amis c'est la seule émission
du monde
[Applaudissements]
mes amis c'est la seule émission du
monde où tu as vraiment peur
intérieurement que le gars ne reviennent
pas on est en direct quand tu sois
emplois seraient remerciés
sarah guetta coin qui a fait l'écho sur
deux tout le monde merci assurera
également tous les coiffeurs
merci les chéris non non et encore en
chine où sont donc ces petits conforts
c'est une honte inquiète pas joué le jeu
fais gaffe à ce que tu fais pas ce que
tu peux faire un dessin qui te fait
regretter
atypique où c'est qu'avec tu sais
qu'avec moi un trait de crayon tu peux
faire un dessin qui peut ruiner ta
carrière juste c'est formidable et je
sais ce qui est maintenant dans sa tête
et dans son coeur dans son corps est en
train de se dire il faut que je passe un
truc qu'ils soient parents en même temps
qu'un point je peux pas le nez il faut
que ça marche il veut absolument il
n'aime pas les chèques soient là la
folie la rai à l'adar cas il sait que si
c'est un point comme je le fais tu aura
pas un gros rire il va mal le vivre sa
religion
la télé janvier c'est pourquoi j'ai
basculé en luchini marocain il le sait
je vais te croquer j'hésite moustache
j'ai envie de te faire une analyse non
moustache une belle passe dans le
classique the gila j'avais une musique
de ces votre brigade du tigre
ouais si vous prenez les missions en
cours de route bienvenue à moustache
[Rires]
[Musique]
moustache et spiritualité la claque est
bonne un peu vous vous sentez seul vous
n'avez pas d'amis ou des animateurs se
cache le visage c'est le petit truc
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
d'aller avec nous les chéris